appello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio di the doubt se
non vi è bastato il terrore della scorsa
volta benvenuti nella mia cassetta
sono contento che questa ragazza doveva
solo andare a scuola l'inizio del gioco
devo andare a scuola o un gatto se la
[ __ ] una scarpa siamo arrivati fino a
qua
l'importante ragazzi e crederci expect o
patronum meno male che non deve usarlo a
proposito ma porca [ __ ] invece deve
usarlo invece invece devo usarono mista
aspetta perché non solo di colpiscono di
colpo una donna meno male testa da culo
molto bene dove vado devo uscire di qua
non lo è pronto stile el 80 che momento
sbagliato per tossire cassa il momento
proprio sbagliato per tossire d'esordio
di cos'è rosso quanto gesù di studi ha
via via via di qui vieni qua perché devo
fare qua dentro sospetto che forse c'è
qualcosa c'è la zia la zia hai una città
very nice questo è giocato della zia è
il giocattolo della zia liszt quarto la
famiglia vieni qua ex petto patronum via
questo porca [ __ ] che male mi sa che la
possibilità mi faccio i cazzi miei anche
se effettivamente a un ascia non vuol
dire che io possa uccidere gli altri non
importa però farci qualcosa lo study
tenacia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no no no no no io santo tagliano ce
l'ho fatta non serva un caz madonnari
bile può dire è passato lunga non è
possibile che tossisci sempre che cazzo
ci sono c'è gente cattiva
non tossire o se tossisci continua a
fare quello che stai facendo anche prima
non puoi tossine st afferma l'opposto
del caso lei tossisce e io me la prendo
nel buco del culo e devi morire quanto
ci mette a morire la gente maledetta
carnevale è basta amori lo so che tira
linee 3 di fila ottimo buono a sapersi
due ore per uccidere questo e basta poi
permette di palme il pd o micaela gaglio
tirato 66 a chat e cioè ma veramente se
imbarazzante zio non moriva più e sono
in corso i più antipatici
sta crollando tutto cos'è regola alla
fine erano queste di ebola che è il
numero spiego tutto a posto la zia
ragazza vada meglio
prego ma prego ma ci mancherebbe altro
ora possa essere morbida anche io
morbida dio santo iddio
dove andare così speriamo di sì magari
io sono perso
non penso che hanno fatto niente di
sbagliato peccato perché la bambina ma
magari mi è entrata dentro doveva andare
così va bene è però allegro meno male
sempre allegria
lo facciamo oh che bello torniamo a casa
che al meno male che sentono da casa ora
che chioccia satana nella nell'esofago
mandiamo a casa bella do cina che brutta
stanza comunque ragazzi via via via
inside my dad sono così stanca
devo dormire è certo che di dormire il
sì se non dormi già ai passa io mi farei
una doccia prima però respiro con
difficoltà
ecco la madonna
abbiamo trovato una copertina del video
presenze se su sexy demoniache figo non
riesce a dormire perché gli incubi data
nè nella tua testa proprio dentro tuo
corpo da ingoiato c'è il tour in goleada
cosa sto telefono ci avrà mai una banana
fine la batteria
perché così buio un interruzione
elettrica tutta città al buio meramente
specchio scusa sia tutto a posto
premi su per vedere
[Musica]
whatsapp minchia the crush regalo
ricordate la zia tutto a posto ma perché
c'è una pari di io ho fotografato tutti
più di così
[ __ ] sorella volta mi sono cagato nelle
mutande stato madonna chi infarto
bellissimo è bellissimo per voi per me
come non mi sono veramente cagato di
sotto dei pac in auto per aiuto è stato
orribile
mio dio al riguardo ricoveri qua fotte
se c'è sempre qualcosa che mi incastra
passaggio di qualche valle oddio
benedetto 9 che starò brega la mia
domanda è la parte che cosa che ci fa un
dramma
non è che o dio dov'è
madonna spettro fedi a tua madre chi ci
appaiono data che è successo a cristo ma
veramente aia sono io che mi sono fatto
una madonna che succede ma ha [ __ ] un
telefono non momento ma non ha giocato
un po più bello studio devono è successo
nome visto
e pestato sono ma un gigante
[Musica]
mi ha pestato un gigante ok non il
telefono non vedo quindi non so quanto
questo modo ti vorrei puntato addosso
per vedere mente ma non vedo cosa hai
capito dei girati dietro girati dietro
soggetti completamente dall'altra parte
ma hanno futuro telefono eccolo corrie
nicchia non vedo niente non vedo niente
non vedo niente c'è il cancello vai
applica cielo perché c'è il telefono
c'era of the rocks sono cagato nelle
mutande
porca [ __ ] e quindi dovevo andare
ancora più avanti che spero sia questo
check point che padre non mi faccio
tutto dai mette in serio che ci ho messo
6 orario neri sono morto 66 volte che
faccio continuo salve anche lei fuori
questa notte allegra vero vorrei fare
due chiacchiere solo che è stata la mia
spetta attenzione attenti al cane
ragazzi
wow respiro con difficoltà ma come le
spirito difficoltà c'è un cane non posso
muovermi cazzo
aiuto tu lì dietro che sei seduto sulla
tale aiuto è una tigre zio e la tigre
gigantesca è un'antica edificata in
orbita se questo patrimonio ha visto
anche lei mi ha tirato una zampata in
faccia sono ancora viva non so come va
bene signorina linda cosa ci fa a
quest'ora non si preoccupi ci sono io
si si faccia lei faccia lei vedo che sta
facendo molto complimenti continui a
fare del suo meglio santo iddio su
cristo
vabbè vado a casa
mica gollum questa è un'altra spettro
pedia ma cosa cacchio è sta roba gare
che brutto singole tanto in questo gioco
e hanno perso le speranze un sacco di
tempo
non mi faccio anche di domande che
cacchio urca pupazza salve
ecco ayachi campioni stai calma 8 penso
l'ho perso ok
verso la via verso l'altra zia
l'hack è male
anche male
came a me ma che male mi ha fatto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
da sei già battuta più bella lì ecco la
battuta più
[Musica]
non è proprio il massimo ma ma almeno il
telefono e chiamare incominciassimo
hanno detto aiutami mi aiuti la
distratta la signora col gatto successo
cosa sta succedendo ed io salve ha visto
che sono stato provato io la boxe fight
vinta io è fortissimo ogni tanto faccio
queste cose anche a casa mia
le vostre un buongiorno ma che cazzo
succede cosa reale e spronata la roba
dopo che lo spa nata io va tutto bene di
in dosi al sicuro sulla mia protezione
sono stata portata a trovati mentre
cercava il mio gatto disperso sarà stato
destino dove solo alle mie maniere tutti
mi chiamano veggente un vero nome ma
ormai questa descrizione mi identifica
riguarda chi c'era non sono sicuri
quello che ti è successo ma ho percepito
qualcosa di oscuro e forte continua sui
diversi hai qualcosa dentro di te che ti
ha preso questa cosa si rafforzerà fino
ad ora solo ha risvegliato vibrazioni
scuri in tutta questa zona temo che sia
all'inizio degli eventi terribili che
stanno per arrivare
ascolta linda non so se sei in grado di
superare questa sfida forse ma forse c'è
una piccola possibilità di sconfiggerla
nel suo regno è diamoci credi ragazzi
questo era 3 d'auto episodi di oggi
spero vi sia piaciuto sempre meglio sto
comunque sempre allegro importante
quello giochi allegri ora vi sia
piaciuto iscritte a canale sia del tasto
mi piace ci piace pilot di the doubt mi
raccomando continuate a seguirlo perché
veramente figo che come sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]
ma